this video is brought to you by
Skillshare hey wisecrack michael here if
you've worked in an office before you've
definitely had to deal with that guy you
know the one I'm talking about he sucks
up to the boss treats minor tasks like
they are matters of life or death hides
knives and hunting bows throughout the
office and skins that face off a dummy
okay so maybe not those last two if it's
not obvious yet I'm talking about paper
salesman beat farmer and Battlestar
Galactica superfan Dwight K Schrute have
you seen the office then you probably
think of him as the embodiment of the
worst possible coworker even if he gets
a little lovable by the end redemption
aside he's unfriendly needlessly
competitive and obsessed with efficiency
in a way that makes him more of an
algorithm than a human at times at 12:45
he sneezed while keeping his eyes open
which I always thought was impossible
but what if Dwight was actually right
now we're not claiming that Dwight's
antics weren't horrifying or just plain
mean but what if his obsession with
machine-like efficiency without regard
for human emotion might end up being
better for his peers
what if paradoxically Dwight is making
his working environment better while
simultaneously being the absolute worst
you're welcome welcome to this wisecrack
edition on the philosophy of Dwight and
spoilers ahead but before we get into it
I'm gonna give a shout out to skill
share skill chair is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
with skill share you can explore new
skills and learn more about the ones you
already have there are four classes on
writing design productivity illustration
and so much more their classes are great
for teaching you how to channel your
creativity into whatever you are working
on right now I recommend productivity
today managing attention in the digital
age with Kevin Cisco the class help me
pay attention to the places I've been
spending most of my time online I can
get lost on social so easily and I'd
much prefer to spend the time writing or
reading I learned how to reduce the
distractions and prioritize what I
actually want to accomplish during my
day the best part is that you can give
léa classes at your own pace and right
from the comfort of your own home a
premium annual membership is less than
$10 a month and right now the first 1000
wisecrack fans that click on the link in
the description can get a two-month free
trial so check out Skillshare today now
back to the show a quick primer on joint
he starts as a top performing paper
salesman and assistant to the regional
manager Michael Scott
he also moonlights as a beet farmer and
is generally convinced he's better and
smarter than everyone else
too many people on this earth they need
a new play throughout the show Dwight
antagonizes his coworkers creating fake
fire panics driving them to faraway
locations and abandoning them are you
insane and just generally being kind of
a dick well thanks for wasting my time
tonight but more than anything the dude
is weirdly obsessed with physical
strength and efficiency to give you a
reference point I'm somewhere between a
snake and a mongoose he also looks
sci-fi and distrust computers we'll get
to that to understand why Dwight might
actually be a good guy in the grand
scheme of things we need to look at a
little concept called acceleration ISM
acceleration ISM has nothing to do with
beat farming or even paper suppliers
rather it's a loosely associated group
of thinkers who argue that sometimes the
best way to improve the system is not to
improve it at all even going so far as
to advocate for speeding up the system
dysfunction figures like Karl Marx Jill
Dollaz and Paul Mason
now acceleration is our mostly talking
about capitalism they think that a
capitalism is bad but be trying to fix
it makes it even worse the best we can
do from their perspective is to let the
global financial system run headfirst
into its own self-destruction pushing
for better working conditions or a more
humane economy for the acceleration 'us
is the philosophical equivalent of this
meme now we're not saved why to some
accidental Che Guevara but if we take
the basic premise that if a system is
bad we should hit the gas and ride it
until the wheels fall off this is
basically what Dwight does
unintentionally or not one key component
of acceleration isn't is technology
technology disrupts it makes the world
go faster and it also causes a pond
what does it mean for technology to
accelerate consider the fact it took us
thousands of years to go from horse and
wagon to car and all of a sudden we said
it and we're flying in airplanes and
going to the moon in the same century
more recently we might consider the
progress from final record to 8-track to
cassette tape to CD - here's thousands
of songs on your iPod just kidding it's
on your phone now instead of course it's
not all fun games and instant access to
the entire discography of the wu-tang
clan
dunder-mifflin for example starts at
ground zero of what technological
acceleration ISM can mean for some
businesses it's a company that provided
what was an essential good for virtually
every company in the 1980s and 90s
rendered obsolete nearly a decade later
by computers
by your own employees calculation you'll
be obsolete in the next five to ten
years wait Ryan said that more
importantly technology in the business
world is about efficiency and speed now
Boyd isn't exactly a fan of computers
since they might do a Skynet but he's
basically trying to turn himself into a
machine wearing hydration backpacks and
peeing into bottles to save time is
basically just a Jeff Bezos fevered
dream or just reality where do I work
isn't about providing a place for folks
to earn a decent living for 40 hours a
week
it's about sacrificing all individuality
and emotion to serve the gods of the
bottom line how would I describe myself
three words
hard-working alpha male jackhammer well
it looks like capitalist efficiency for
some looks like joblessness and
obsolescence for others as British
acceleration is Steve Goodman notes we
all live in an operating system set up
by the accelerating triad of war
capitalism and emergent AI and that
operating system doesn't really give a
about traditional business or human
values saws the scary AI
Dwight is all about this even if he
spurns consumer technology lest it make
him weak what if we don't want to use a
blackberry because they are stupid and
pointless rather he takes on the
technological rationale of speed and
efficiency even at the cost of basic
human dignity take the time he was
tasked by Michael of picking out a new
healthcare plan for Dunder Mifflin
does he take into consideration the
diversity of his co-workers health needs
to pick
a plan that offers the most
comprehensive care number one inverted
penis could you mean vagina because if
you do I want that covered
hell no he slashes things down to a
bare-bones plan to save the company
money i slashed benefits to the bone I
saved this company money was I too harsh
maybe I don't believe in coddling people
his thought process isn't grounded in
what's best for human beings it's
grounded in the tenets of capitalist
efficiency which he values over humanity
how many people can I fire
none you're picking a healthcare plan
okay we'll table that for the time being
now you might be asking how is this good
but consider this what Dwight is doing
is probably not much worse than what
anyone from corporate looking to slash
cost would have done you know the whole
reason that we're doing this is to save
money so usually to pick a provider and
then choose the cheapest plan instead
Dwight by embracing the logical extreme
of cost cutting kisses everyone off to
the point that they rebel his actions
force his co-workers to band together
and demand something better and maybe
without Dwight pushing things they would
have merely accepted whatever garbage
health plan they were offered why did
you put Dwight in charge of that you did
a horrible job Dwight did you raise
benefits I most certainly did not
oh come on that's horrible this is what
the more progressive advocates for
acceleration ISM hope that by making
reality more extreme things will
actually get better and this isn't a
completely new theory of change as
throughout history the most significant
revolutions come from extreme
circumstances think of the French
Revolution a product of dire poverty
among the peasants and opulent wealth
amongst the ruling aristocracy rather
than sitting around waiting for change
acceleration is what too poor fuel on
the fire we can contrast' White's brutal
logic with that of his superior Michael
Scott who makes terrible fiscal
decisions because he's prioritizing the
feelings of the people around him over
efficiency Ryan wants everything in our
company to be about emails and IMS but I
think he is forgetting about the
original instant message
letters attached to baskets of food
whether it's for selfish reasons or not
Michael airs on the side of people over
profits good manager doesn't fire people
he hires people if Dwight embodies the
futuristic politics of acceleration ISM
then Michael embodies an old-school
liberal political philosophy that places
emphasis on a decent life for all of his
employees all you have to tolerate a lot
when you're part of a family it's not a
family it's a workplace rather than
Dwight's dystopian vision of efficiency
Michael seems to prefer something like
you would have seen in the Rust Belt in
the 1950s where working a good job at
the factory meant everyone could afford
to start a family and own a home but the
good thing about the American Dream is
that you can just go to sleep and try it
all again the next night well this all
sounds very nice and acceleration astute
Lu that it's about as likely to make a
comeback as video rental stores Dwight's
attitude is more at home in our
contemporary era of techno capitalism
than Michaels old-school people based
Iowa business a Silicon Valley culture
transforms into political ideology
principles like hyper efficiency and
automation are becoming touchstones in
industries ranging from jet propulsion
to healthcare to home cooking
this innovation involves an open embrace
of capitalism in all of its techno
utopian glory joyed affirms this type of
ideology when he hunts down time thieves
in the company who are wasting even a
moment of their working day on personal
inefficiencies time thief time thief
fire him do it you've really never
stolen any company time
never and while Dwight might fear and
detests computers it's fitting that his
one true worthy adversary is a computer
that also sells paper
Dwight takes this competitor on wins and
in doing so shows that he might be more
machine than man after all but we're not
arguing that Dwight is secretly a
monster only for the sake of inspiring
revolution from his co-workers far from
it he just wants power and control the
Japanese camp guards of world war ii
always chose one man to kill whenever a
batch of new prisoners arrived I always
wondered how they chose the man
who was to die I think I would have been
good at choosing the person we see this
tendency at play when Dwight is
momentarily given what he thinks is
absolute rule over the office our
ruthlessness comes to the surface the
moment he's in power over his own
kingdom complete with his own evil queen
chicken be in charge of the women he
seems to be implicitly acknowledging the
inefficiencies of traditional democratic
structures as he installs his own profit
prioritizing system Dwight rarely gets
explicit about his politics but we know
that he has some definite tendencies
towards authoritarianism at one point
Jim helped stride out by printing out
talking points for a speech he's given I
did download speeches from some of
history's famous dictators like this one
originally given by Benito Mussolini and
because Dwight is Dwight he is
immediately inspired and empowered by
the fascist prose blood alone moves the
wheels of history and of course there
are the frequent hints that Dwight's
German ancestors might have been literal
Nazis my grandpa Mannheim is a hundred
and three and still puttering around
down in Argentina I tried to go visit
him once but my travel visa was
protested by the Shoah foundation Dwight
is accelerating for accelerating safe
not to help break the system and is
affinity for fascism eerily resembles
the dangers of acceleration it's
thinking but let's return to the Dwight
michael dichotomy of acceleration is
immerses old-school liberalism rather
than viewing technology and innovation
as a mechanism to unleash the spirit of
capitalism to remake the world in its
image Michael seems to view technology
as a threat to the traditions of the
American workplace we have learned that
you can't teach an old dog new tricks
because it's illegal if Dwight is trying
to move beyond the need for human labor
Michael can't imagine a world or he's
not spending 40 plus hours a week
hanging out under harsh fluorescent
lighting with his buds in the end life
and business are about human connections
and computers are about trying to murder
you in a lake and to me the choice is
easy and we see the tension between
Dwight and Michael's perspectives when
they go on a covert mission to gather
Intel from a local mom-and-pop a paper
business Michael recoils and horror at
the thought of destroying the business
of these good wholesome people
Dwight views them as just the acceptable
collateral damage of the free market
paradoxically though by making the
workplace much more pleasant and humane
in the short term Michaels approach
actually keeps things stuck right where
they are
no one is forming a secret union to
overthrow Michael just because of the
occasional appearance of prison Mike a
prison Mike speaking of prison Mike he
invents the character after his workers
realized they'd rather be in a prison
than at work or realization that comes
so slowly because their work prison is
obfuscated by Michael's friendly antics
Dwight who makes things more unbearable
in the immediate sense can actually
create the conditions for change by
taking systems to their logical extreme
Dwight even explicitly recognizes his
logic when he becomes landlord of the
office building and his antics go too
far
he takes elaborate measures to save on
building cost including half ply toilet
paper don't get me started on how
coddled the modern anus is afterwards he
has a legitimate showdown with Pam who
threatens to find a new office Dwight in
typical Dwight fashion thinks of his
relationship with his tenants as a war
owning the building as a war between the
landlord and the tenant not a literal
war unfortunately but I am using the
same tactics but eventually realizes
that the best vampires don't drain all
the blood from their victims at once
they say the best vampires don't bleed
their victims dry but give them the
strength so that they can bounce back
only to be fed on again in a nutshell
Dwight is realizing that his
acceleration his practices will lead to
open revolt and that he must reign in
his short-term greed for long term
stability and whether it be Silicon
Valley or Dwight Schrute the process of
acceleration can either make things way
better or much worse with not a lot in
between and a recent example Silicon
Valley's desire to develop things like
facial recognition technology cause
people who see this technology as a wild
invasion of privacy to organize and
fight against it complete with the last
week tonight take down so okay in the
Terminator Skynet is evil reigns down
death from the sky
but in China's Skynet is good yeah not a
difference oh that's the difference is
it
so maybe Dwight's tyranny will
ultimately lead to a better workplace
but maybe it won't by the end of the
series he establishes himself as the Kim
junk ill of Scranton Pennsylvania paper
and people seem okay with it maybe
Dwight hold on to this power and just
makes things even worse for everyone at
Dunder Mifflin firing as many folks as
he can and creating a living hell for
those stuck there get out what does that
mean it's a colloquial way of saying
you're fired
the danger of acceleration ISM is as its
critics have noted that maybe the wheels
won't come flying off maybe things won't
get better maybe we'll just end up with
Dwight as the boss forever but what do
you think the things have to get worse
to get better should we encourage it or
is it just too risky let us know what
you think in the comments a huge thanks
to our amazing patrons for supporting
the channel and our podcast hit that
subscribe button and as always thanks
for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]